hi everyone its Jonah here as you are
requested I'm going to show you a full
mil pen to help you to kickstart your
weight loss goal this new pen is based
on eating clean and is a 1,500 calories
diet so depending on your weight and
your goal you have to adjust the
calories accordingly so before we start
I want to share with you 10 things that
you need to do in order for this meal
plan to be successful and for you to
lose weight successfully the first tip
is to prepare your meals in bulk so
instead of stressing out what your next
move will be prepare meals that can last
you up to two or three days therefore if
you're busy the next day all you need to
do is to just pack it in your bag and go
the second point to remember is that
these meals are interchangeable so you
can have your breakfast or snack large
for breakfast snack 15
and vice-versa the next point is to only
use and prepare high quality food so
chicken fish brown rice brown bread
vegetables no white bread no white rice
no prepaid food and no ready meals and
remember to adjust the portion size and
calories according to the product you
use so what I use my log is similar to
what you use so always remember to read
the food labels the next point is very
important you must drink at least three
to four liters of water a day
three liters minimum and if you're
working out you have to do more than
that okay
the next point is that you have to eat
every three to four hours this is not a
diet this is not to starve you but this
is going to make you loose weight and /
fat efficiently and if you can't always
prepare your food the night before
and keep it in the fridge so that you'll
have an easier morning and you help you
to stay on track all right point number
a is to stick this your plan on your
fridge remind yourself what you should
eat in order to achieve your goal and
the next point is to keep a food journal
this will tell you exactly what you're
eating you would help you towards your
weight loss goal and therefore you will
know when you're cheating the last point
is to make it really effective trying to
work out five to six times a week if you
can't go for 3 to 4
but we cannot really boost your
maximalism arm and therefore it makes
your body more efficient in putting fat
so those are the ten points and now I'm
going to show you an idea of what the
meal plan would look like you can be
creative and make your own meals as long
as you have these four ingredients in
most of the meals so the first is about
3 ounces of protein the second is one
complex car third is one healthy fat and
the last one is unlimited vegetables all
fits okay so if you have those whole
things in each film you are on the right
track so let's start with the most
important your breakfast every morning
before I have my breakfast Oh drink half
a liter of water so drink half a liter
of water before your breakfast all right
what's for breakfast I'm going to show
you how to prepare an extremely simple
and healthy avocado and eggs on toast
this is extremely simple place packed
full of protein you can prep it the
night before and store in the fridge
servant and just pretty only Tristan
the ingredients you need are half of an
avocado two eggs white and two for X and
one slice of toast what you've got here
that's your complex carbs that's your
protein and that's your healthy fat and
vegetables at the same time so two whole
eggs and two egg whites
okay so just slice it and really mesh it
up
so once you've cut your eggs into a
really really small mesh of pieces slice
your avocado into small cubes as well
and just scoop it up and just mix it in
with your eggs
now what is all propping next what you
want to do is just to put half of that
onto one slice of toast okay
so there you have it that's my protein
packs healthy breakfast to kickstart
your day avocado with eggs on toast
what I've been purchased now was for two
servings so half of it I've store it
into a container and I'll keep it in the
fridge to be eaten tomorrow and to
finish my breakfast I have my cup of
green tea to kick start my day all right
so that's for breakfast and that is
about 267 calories now between breakfast
and snack what you need to do drink
another half liter of water so what's
for snack I'm going to show you how to
make this lovely sharing fruit with
Greek yogurt and dispatcher nuts only
three ingredients and it's only about
290 calories but this is going to fill
you up what we'll need is share a fruit
I'll pick any of your favorite fruit
right now because it's summer I love
sharing food pick your favorite nuts for
me I like pistachio nuts and use Greek
yogurt if you can it's because Greek
yogurt has more protein than your
ordinary you're good so the options are
you can have this separately as a
mid-morning snack or you can combine
them all together so let me show you how
to combine them so I've sliced my
sharing fruits out into small slices you
can grind your nuts if you want to like
what I've done and I'm just going to
combine all this there you go you're
really healthy full of nutrition snack
which will really really fill you up and
it's only 200 and writing
calories now that it's fitted snake
eyelash time what should you do you got
that right bring water another half
liter of water before your lunch time
the lunch we're going to make this lunch
pack creamy grilled chicken wrap again
really simple only five ingredients
about 100 gram of chicken which I've
seasoned with a little bit of pepper
herbs and also one teaspoon of olive oil
and big letters lots of letters and then
about 50 gram of cottage cheese that
will provide you with the healthy fat
protein as well and very complex car is
to choose seated wrap so just slice the
letters into small chances events easy
to wrap we want lots of vegetables in
our lunch okay all right so now just put
the cottage cheese into the chicken and
then we'll give it a creamy texture so
just mix it up and then we're going to
place it on the rap and stop rapping a
lot of vegetables here for vegetarian
the alternative is that you can use tofu
oh X oh god I don't know whether I'll be
able to roll this up right now
it looks too big too much for the wrap
now's my challenge to wrap it up
there you go this is your lunch pack
creamy grilled chicken wrap really
simple same thing you can prep it the
night before put it into your lunchbox
and bring it to school or what and this
wrap only contains 400 calories and all
of them are healthy ingredients so
prepping the night before like I always
say because then you are able to plan
and control what you even date after so
you can choose to drink your water with
your lunch all remember to drink your
half liter of water after lunchtime hmm
so what's for your afternoon snack well
I've got my power berries smoothie
really simple but we will give you lots
of energy it's great as a pre-workout
snack or as a post-workout snack really
simple three ingredients 200 grams of
mixed frozen berries of fresh berries
120 gram of Greek yogurt and 1
tablespoon of honey and also just a
little bit of water if you think your
smoothie is too thick so what we're
going to do now is to fix all the
ingredients into a smoothie blender and
just planning there you go your power
berries smoothie every time I drink this
it really fills me up and I tend not to
crave for anything else so like I said
before you can make it beforehand make
it the night before put it into two
bottles if you make more and keep in the
fridge and
bring it with you to work it's that
simple and it will keep your field so
try this out and let me know so now
that's nice over it's between dinner
time you have done 2 liters of water
come on you've one little more to go
grab a bottle of water and drink another
half liter of water all right I'll see
you do it to the time it's dinner time
and this is your face bill for the day
and also probably your last meal for
dinner we are having grilled salmon with
spinach and corn on top of sweet potato
so really simple four main ingredients
so to start off with you will need 3
ounces of 7 or any other fish or if
you're a vegetarian you can go for tofu
finish and corn unlimited so have as
much vegetables as you want and about
150 grams of sweet potato so to prepare
this meal I've grade my salmon I've
meshed my sweet potato I've added a
little bit of black pepper and mix herbs
and I plug in boiled my spinach and corn
and also I've drizzled a little bit of
lemon on top of the whole thing so this
is your dinner simple delicious and it's
only 359 calories so that's basically a
full day meal plan and remember before
you sleep drink your fire half a litre
of water and you have completed 3 litres
for the day remember as long as you have
these four ingredients in most of your
meals you will be fine so your protein
about 3 ounces 1 complex car one healthy
fats and one I mean unlimited vegetables
or fruits
and most of the news the average
calories count should be about 350
calories every single meal that I've
shown you can be prepared beforehand so
they can store in the fridge and bring
it to school or work the next day
remember you can be as creative as you
want with your meals you don't have to
follow what I've done check out the
description box for more alternatives
and I would encourage that as long as
you eat clean and use high quality
Beauty or on the right track so to begin
with try to do it for six weeks and
hopefully eventually this will be your
life style to make your meal plan and
even more successful one I would
encourage you to introduce a cheat meal
Oh what I would call it a reward meal
yes that's right
once a week treat yourself to a reward
meal choose what you want to eat indulge
in it don't feel guilty but the key is
moderation so I would encourage you to
start this new nutritional journey over
the weekends go to the grocery store buy
all the ingredients you need for at
least a week plan every single meal out
for the next week put it on the fridge
and follow the meal plan once you've
achieved it at the end of the week treat
yourself to a reward meal I hope I've
helped you out don't forget to like this
page share this video and please do
subscribe to my youtube channel for more
nutritional and fitness videos
you